[Musique]
c'est
bonsoir et oui nous sommes là gérard
majax et moi-même fidèles à notre rendez
vous quotidien et je dois dire qu'hier
alors deux candidats ont été
extraordinaires n'est ce point gérard
ils ont trouvé très vite les allumettes
magnétique à weibo femmes titre marque
anglaise le monsieur qui a trouvé a
quand même vu cette expérience pendant
tout l'été donc ils avaient plus de
chances que des concurrents du truc
nouveau
enfin il a quand même gagné 3,13 france
qui n'est déjà pas si mal le deuxième
truc n'ayant pas été trouvé
la magie de la bouteille hier il valait
300 francs aujourd'hui 300 enfants ce
qui fait quand même 600 francs s'ils
gagnent les importerons 600 francs tout
de suite vous savez je vais vous
présenter nos six candidats qui ont été
sélectionnés avant l'émission pour
parler à tour de rôle les enfants numéro
je vous présente tout de suite la
candidate numéro un
mademoiselle mam'zelle de chemin de
paris parlez bien fort s'il vous plaît
numéro 2
leclerc de rouen numéro 3 clôt didier de
collobrières où ça se trouve c'est
monsieur dans le var près de toulon
merci candidat numéro 4 monsieur auclair
de tours candidate numéro 5
liliane claude du mesnil-saint-denis et
candidat numéro 6 monsieur sur des paris
alors vous êtes très attentif à votre
récepteur qui est en face de vous et je
pense que nous pouvons envoyer tout de
suite notre premier truc
la magie de la bouteille
j'ai un tout avec une paille
une bouteille de bière on rentre la
paille dans la bouteille de bière et
maintenant le problème c'est d'essayer
d'essayer par un simple petit geste
magique de soulever la bouteille avec
l'appareil
c'est possible mais pas grâce à un petit
génie qui est dans la bouteille
simplement un tout petit truc âge et oui
c'était le génie de la bouteille je
m'étais trompé candidate numéro 1
mademoiselle bas jama de paris vous avez
sans doute des questions à poser à
gérard majax si vous mettez une épingle
à la partie inférieure de l'appareil ah
je vous ai vus jouer tout à l'heure et
qui n'est pas l'un vous pensé à ça une
épingle dans la paille mais comment la
partie inférieure vous le mettez dans la
bouteille et ongles sortir tout droit à
l épingle se mettra en travers pour
empêcher au oui comme on fait pour
récupérer des fois un objet qui est
tombé qui est très loin hors d'atteinte
écoutez c'est pas mal du tout ce que
vous nous dites là mais c'est pas ça
arrête
il est terrible quand il des numéros de
monsieur leclerc de royer vous mine un
petit fils qui traverserait le boulot un
petit film louis un fils en ayant percé
les les deux extrémités du goulot du
dôme blanc et avec une entaille dans
l'appareil vous savez vous percer un
boulot difficile ça ou alors à la
surface de la à la mode est percé vous
savez que nos trucs sont toujours des
choses très simples que tout le monde
peut faire chez soi après aux amis qui
n'ont pas vu l'émission il ya un truc
alors versé ce serait trop long et trop
difficile non non ce n'est pas ça toute
façon il n'y a pas de faits de monsieur
candidat numéro 3 monsieur didier quand
vous mettez le la paille dans la
bouteille
au moment où vous la retirez vos lapins
c est un vide d'air qui se produit et la
bouteille mais vous n'êtes pas ingénieur
monsieur non vous pourriez l'être avec
non je vous aider à le faire si la ola
ça c'est très original oui mais écoutez
je vais vous dire votre
théorie mériterait d'être essayé c'est
maintenant et qu'elle marche parce qu'en
tout cas ce n'est pas du tout le truc
simple qu'on emploie mais là vous avez
sûrement des possibilités qui pourraient
intéresser de l'aéronautique un harry
candidat numéro 86 auclair n'y aurait-il
pas un produit dans de la paille et en
soufflant ce produit inspiré l'ère de la
bouteille maintien à noter bien c'est
intéressant
en soufflant ça fait inspiré leur navire
par un produit chimique lors du don
c'est pas un produit courant
non vous connaissez un produit qui ont
mal en q1 mais en tout cas c'était une
réponse originale qui malheureusement
monsieur je le regrette n'est pas la
bonne candidate numéro ça que madame
clos du mesnil saint denis
vous mettez un petit objet dans la
paille pour la rendre rigide un petit
objet pour la rendre jupe et vous
coincez la paille devenu rigide dans le
fond de la bouteille pour la soulever si
je comprends bien chère madame ce serait
un objet qui ferait s'écarter n'a pas et
qui la ferait grossir dans toute la
longueur de la page baguettes de bois si
vous voulez et puis alors vous coin vous
quoi seriez la paille dans l'intérieur
de la bouteille non ce n'est pas cela du
tout mais je regrette parce que c'était
un ingénieux candidat numéro 6 monsieur
savate je pense il ya aucun accessoire
une réponse de la candidate précédente
et est presque bonne en ce sens que la
paille elle-même suffit est à s'ériger
pour soulever la bouteille il suffit
d'introduire la paille dans la bouteille
de la casse et enfin de lui faire faire
un coude mais avec moi à main avec moi
je crois que vous êtes proches monsieur
de la solution
venez essayer tenez prenez la paille
montrez nous ce que vous faites c'est un
endroit c'est recouvre que même si
l'appareil était plus longue
[Musique]
le jingle monsieur vous êtes loin de la
solution pas trop loin mais loin quand
même merci je regrette
eh bien merci mais oui merci le génie de
la bouteille n'ayant pas été trouvée
demain je vous le rappelle il vaudra 900
francs et oui ça monte ça monte ça monte
et tout de suite si vous le voulez bien
et bien nous regardons ensemble notre
deuxième truc casse un tour avec du
poivre
après avoir mis un peu d'eau dans un
verre d'ailleurs jusqu'au bord on
remplit bien la surface de l'eau de
boire une mince couche apparaît si on
trempe un doigt dans ce poivre le poire
se rapproche tout doucement du doigt la
gauche n'est pas rompu rajoutons encore
un peu de poivre et regardez bien ce qui
va se passer maintenant je trempe un
doigt hélas le poivre ces cartes il fuit
mon doigt
cela semble invraisemblable c'est tout à
fait contraire à ce qui doit se passer
pourquoi et pourquoi parce que c'est un
poivre catrice yeux et oui tout de suite
nous demandons à nouveau pour notre
deuxième truc à notre candidate numéro
un
mademoiselle benjamin avez vous des
questions à poser un gérard majax le
deuxième fois vous trompez votre jour
dans une autre liquide à écouter là je
dois c'est délicat pour moi de vous
répondre mais tel que vous formulez
votre question je suis obligé de vous
dire non je ne trompe pas mon doigt dans
un autre l'équipe candidat numéro dé
monsieur leclerc alors trempé vous votre
doigt dans un autre produit oui d'abord
la deuxième fois ce que vous mettez du
poivre réellement à hawija alors là je
vous dis tout de suite nous ne nous
avons aucun cas de trucage télévision ou
cinématographiques pour vous trompez
vous avez des conditions réelles de
l'expérience
donc la deuxième fois lorsque vous
trempez votre doigt il est plus les plus
comme la première fois donc vous avez
mis quelque chose sur votre doigt
c'est vrai je suis obligé de l'avouer un
sage alors à base d'huile un produit à
base d'huile nous faire écarter la non
non monsieur je revais ce n'est pas la
tête aider notre troisième candidat
monsieur didier sûrement deuxième
candidat a été brillant d'ailleurs il a
facilité les choses
prochain candidat qui est perplexe je
crois que vous mettez de la salive de la
salle ils écoutent et 0,7 à le regarder
je vous et vous étiez comme ça oui si
vous étiez en train d'essayer je me
disais mais qu'est ce qui fait que son
bras sans la bouche un monsieur de cet
âge là bas maintenant non c'est vrai
maintenant j'ai compris vous et ifs en
train de chercher la solution lancée par
cela candidat numéro 4 monsieur auclair
je pensais comme le monsieur du deuxième
homme le deuxième le doigt avec de
l'huile sur deux doigts et bien non
monsieur c'est lui ne réussit pas du
tout nous avons fait l'élaboration de
notre truc disons des quantités décès et
je peux vous dire que l'huile quelle
qu'elle soit ne réussira là je pense que
vous avez un produit dès le départ et le
fait de mettre le doigt dans l'eau
retire le produit que vous n'avez plus
au deuxième tour ah oui c'est une et si
vous n'êtes pas chimiste là non parce
que la bonne explication est très
poussée on a du mal à la suivre
d'ailleurs donc il y aurait dès le
départ un produit dans nos venant vous
avez mis un produit d'une départ à votre
doigt oui et le fait de le tremper dans
l'eau ce qu'on prend un bon le produit
s'est rapproché le poivre mais le fait
de le tremper dans l'eau le produit par
dans l'eau et vous ne l'avez plus au
bout du doigt
alors quand pour tremper votre gloire à
ce mot
x écoutez je vais prendre des notes
parce que c'est pas du tout ça est
vicieux le dernier rendez-vous avait une
réponse je ne sais pas si je souffle sur
mon doigt le deuxième tour ce cas non
monsieur souffler n'est pas jouer pour
cette eau là excusez moi bien notre
deuxième truc n'a pas été trouvé
aujourd'hui demain il vaudra 600 francs
si vous le voulez bien tout de suite
nous allons regarder les deux trucs qui
passeront demain à l'antenne à 19h45 le
poivre oui le poivre capricieux et le
génie de la bouteille un tour avec une
paille et une bouteille de bière on
rentre la paille dans la bouteille de
bière et maintenant le problème c'est
d'essayer d'essayer par un simple petit
geste magique de soulever la bouteille
avec l'appareil
c'est possible mais pas grâce à un petit
génie dans la bouteille simplement un
tout petit truc âge un tour avec du
poivre
après avoir mis un peu d'eau dans un
verre d'ailleurs jusqu'au bord on
remplit bien la surface de l'eau de
boire une mince couche apparaît si on
trempe un doigt dans ce poivre le poivre
se rapproche tout doucement du doigt la
couche n'est pas rompu rajoutons encore
un peu de poivre et regardez bien ce qui
va se passer maintenant je trempe un
doigt hélas le poivre ces cartes il fuit
mon doigt
cela semble invraisemblable c'est tout à
fait contraire à ce qui doit se passer
pourquoi
[Musique]